il est 20h45 on est en direct enlevez
vos pancartes euh enlevez vos pancartes
vous n AZ plus besoin merci il est 20h45
vous pouz enlevez vos pancartes vous n'
avez plus besoin merci vous pouvez
mettre par terre merci euh il est 20h45
on est en direct merci d'être là on va
passer tout de suite au témoin du jour
on va parler de dianis Marchal et Bruno
Vandelli rappelez-vous lundi Lionel team
nous a fait de grosses révélations
concernant les deux chorégraphes et
Lionel était le compagnon de la
locataire de Bruno Vandelli au moment où
la relation entre Yanis et Bruno a
débuté et bien aujourd'hui pénelope l'ex
compagne de l'Onel team souhaite lui
répondre elle veut donner sa ver des Fas
et on accueille pénéope avec plaisir
avant tout on reg regarde les
déclarations deonel et pénéope va bien
sûr réagir dans un instant oui première
fois que je rencontre Yanis Marshall
c'était entre août et septembre
2005 et je suis dans cet appartement là
je dis tiens c'est marrant il y a un
jeune dans le salon c'est qui et donc ma
copine de l'époque me dit c'est Yanis je
te le présente c'est vrai qu'il avait il
était un peu foufou et je m' perçois que
c'était le petit am de Bruno elle me
disait écoute par contre il faudra être
discret sur sur le fait que Yanis soit
là parce qu'en fait il a pas vraiment
droit d'être ici parce qu'en fait la
mère de Yanis est contre cette relation
m'avait dit exactement ne dis rien faut
que tu sois vraiment discret
là-dessus merci Pénélope d'être avec
nous merci beaucoupci pour l'invitation
au contraire on veut vraiment nous avoir
toutes les versions et au contraire on
est content que vous soyez là parce que
c'est vrai qu'on veut que vous
rétablissiez votre
vérité 2005 vous étiez en couple donc
avec lonel Team qui qui est juste là
d'ailleurs exactement ça c'est pas le ça
c'est pas sa pas de mentir là il est là
merci oh là
là bah pas depuis un moment non j'étais
allé le voir jouer au théâtre il a un
petit bout de tempsah voyz ou pas non
non tu en très bon terme B très bien
bien j'espère que ça va durer il est
super sympa monsieur donc vous étiez
surtout la colocataire de Bruno à
l'époque oui en fait moi je louais un
appartement et alors je tiens à revenir
sur ce sujet je n'étais pas propriétaire
de l'appart je ne soulouais pas à Bruno
je l'ébergeis et à l'inverse lui m'avait
filé ses clés à canes on se connait
depuis que j'ai 5 ans is donc lui il
croyait que vous étiez propriétaire non
c'est Lionel team voilà voilà mais
c'était il y a longtemps il a d oublié
c'est pas voilà c'est pas très grave ça
mon Lionel on t'aime quand même je pas
problème avec le fisque mon chat tu vois
voilà il était Yanis Yanis il était
régulièrement là il était en couple avec
Bruno ou pasépoque oui il venait à la
maison ils étaient en couple ils étaient
d'accord vous avvez l'air très heureux
d'ailleurs connaissiez son âge ou pas du
tout bah moi je faisais j'avais
l'impression qu'il avait plus ou moins
le même age que moi parce que je faisais
un peu plus jeune lui il faisait un peu
plus vieux je pense et ouis donc je me
suis pas je me suis jamais posé la
question de l'âge très honnêtement euh
vous avez vraiment dit à à Lionel team
de ne pas en parler ou pas du tout alors
je je me souviens pas du tout avoir dit
ça honnêtement j'ai j'ai bondi devant ma
télé quand j'ai vu j'ai entendu ça parce
que j'ai dû lui dire en effet que sa
mère n'était pas pour la relation mais
parfois quand j'avais 25 ans j'ai eu des
petits amis mes parents n'étaient pas
pour ces relations là non plus donc je
pense ça n en tout cas rien à voir avec
l'âge que je ne connaissais pas et qui
de toute façon à l'époque était dans
l'âge légal parce qu'on parle de on
parle bien de 2005 ouais c'est ça
octobre novembre 2005 oui voilà par donc
il avait 16 il a il a eu 16 ans le le 11
novembre 2005 vous vous avez été en
contact avec Bruno Vandelli récemment ou
pas du tout il a 10 minutes ouais à 10
minutes d'accord il conteste toutes ses
accusations alors Bruno reconnaît qu'il
a eu une histoire avec Yanis mais il l'a
jamais violé d'cord d'accord donc
aujourd'hui pour vous il s'agit
s'agit pas de viol ni d'agression
sexuelle non voilà non mais simple vous
le disiez ce soir ah ben moi je suis per
je serais très déçu si j'apprenais que
je me suis trompée parce que moi je
crois réellement qu' a pas eu ça
vraiment je je le crois il me l'a dit il
me l'a dit dans dans le blanc des yeux
je connais l'homme au-delà de l'artiste
je connais l'homme depuis que j'ai 5 an
c'est comme mon grand frère je le vois
réellement pas faire ça il y a un énorme
battage médiatique autour de ça qui est
en train de vraiment faire beaucoup de
mal à Bruno et c'est pour ça que j'ai
souhaité j'ai accepté l'invitation pas
que j'ai souhaité venir préférait venir
pour autre chose bien sûr bah la
prochaine fois P avec plaisir donc
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez donc à à
Lionel sur sa versionir ah bien alors
cette histoire de billets d'avion dont
je ne ai jamais parlé parce que déjà
elle n'existe pas c'est quoi l'histoire
des billets d'avion je me rappelle plus
billets d'avion pour soisant revenir des
étatsunisou d'accord donc je aurais
parlé et c'est étonnant parce que moi je
la connais pas c de billet d'avion et
j'en ai parlé à Bruno qui ne la connaî
pas non plus d'accord
euh et puis le fait de de ne pas le fait
de ne pas dire que que qu'ils étaient
ensemble parce que c'est étonnant parce
qu'on allait dans des restaurants dans
le Marais assez branché hyper fréquenté
donc ça en fait ça n'a pas vraiment de
sens de devoir se taire sur une relation
et ensuite d'aller dans le Marais
s'afficher devant tout le monde il y a
d'autres élèves qui sont plein du
comportement de de Bruno euh il paraît
il a d'ailleurs été mis à l'écart de sa
propre école de danse à cause de ça que
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai du tout alors
c'est lui important que vous le disiez
donc c'est pas vrai voilà c'est lui qui
a tenu parce que il s'est quand même
pris un coup he va norm c'est quand même
un sacré coup quand on se lève un matin
même moi c'est pas du tout moi qui étais
concerné quand j'ai entendu ça ça m'a ça
m'a vraiment attristé pour lui donc il
s'est mis à l'écart et l'école est tenue
par l'équipe pédagogique habituelle et
le centre de danse tourne là à ce moment
en ce moment il doit y avoir des cours à
l'heure actuelle au cent oui pas il doit
y avoir il cours quand ici la maman de
Yanis parle notamment d'emprise est-ce
que de ce que vous en savez vous aviez
ce sentiment ou de ce que vous en avez
évoqué avec Bruno Vandelli ce rapport
peut-être avec cette cette grande
différence d'âge d'emprise moi j'ai pas
l'impression que l'emprise avait un
rapport avec une différence d'âge c'est
que pour moi quand on est amoureux il y
a forcément une emprise parce que moi
toutes les personnes dont j'ai pu tomber
amoureuse il a forcément quelque chose
qui me fascinait chez eux donc quelque
part ça c'est une forme d'emprise
amoureuse de Lionel oui tu éta es
fasciné par lui j'étais fasciné par lui
le chanteur qu'il était tout ça ouais
moi
toujours forcément sinon on peut pas
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un et donc en
ce sens moi je trouve qu'on utilise le
terme en prise un petit peu on on s
c'est pas trop le le sujet juste
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur les dates
parce que donc
c'est c'est c'est parce que c'est le
gros point en fait c'est le grand point
oui c'est vrai donc vous dites qu'il
avait 16 ans vous vous dites qu'il était
beaucoup plus jeune en fait moi je lui
ai pas demandé son âge à l'époque je
sais juste que je l'ai vu en 2005 moi
dans l'appartement de pénéope c'est tout
l' vu en novembre il est né le 11
novembre 89 il avit 16 ans non je l'ai
vu moi je pense que après ça remonte à
20 ans je pense que je l'ai vu en août
septembre donc je sais que à l'époque
pour pour ce que je me rappelle p c'est
impossible couper la parole parce que
Bruno fait sa prérentrée et Bruno
n'était jamais à Paris en
septembre 2 mois de différence 2005 mais
c'était quand même en 2005 donc il ais
mais ça se joue à de mois toute
l'histoire
donc mais pour pénélog vous qui
connaissait bien Bruno oui Lionel nous
disait que quand il les voyait tous les
deux Yanis et Bruno à Paris la relation
avait commencé avant il en était certain
alors ça moi Bruno me l'a jamais dit je
ne pense pas sinon il l'aurait dit on se
racontait tout mais c'estàd si se
connaissait il se connaissaiit il était
élève chez Bruno ils é après ils ont
développé une forme d'amitié après moi
j'étais pas là tout le temps moi je ne
pense réellement pas je parle en mon nom
je ne pense réellement pas qu'il soit
passé quelque chose avant BR m'a dit que
ça a commencé à Paris donc il a attendu
qu'il est 16 ans et là bim c'est bon
c'est la relation qui commence et avant
il il attendu parce qu'il est il est pas
idiot d'accord est-ce que vous avez à
dire à pén parce que elle est pas du
tout d'accord avec vre version là alors
pour revenir sur les billets d'avion je
n' pas parlé de billets d'avion moi j'ai
jamais dit que c'était j'ai juste dit
que c'était selon Yanis que c'était
Bruno qui lui payait des billets d'avion
moi j'ai juste dit que Yanis m'avait dit
ça je savais pas en fait s'il venait en
train ou en billet ou en avion donc
c'est la seule chose que je dis autre
chose j'ai jamais dit autre chose euh
j'ai juste dit aussi que tu m'avais dit
clairement de ne pas trop faire de bruit
parce que voilà c'était un petit peu
c'est un peu délicat de voir Bruno avec
avec Yanis donc moi je me vois mal àer
donner demander âge de Yanis et et
surtout demander à Bruno quel âge à
Yanis à ce moment-là et moi j'en suis
certain l'histoire n'a pas commencé à
Paris jamais de la vie en fait je vois
pas Yanis débarquer dans l'appart dit ah
c'est c'est cool c'est le nouveau petit
ami de de Bruno mais il se connaissait
il se connaissait évidemment il éta élèv
depuis longtemps il se connaissaient tu
peux connaître des gens tuis pas
obligé résumé pour avoir les deux
versions vous votre version c'est voilà
vous c'est c'est quoi votre version moi
ma version elle est très simple elle
bougera pas c'est en septembre que j'ai
rencontré Yanis pour la premièreis de ma
vie dans l'appartement cour saintam
Milon et en plus c'est trè très
important c'est que j'ai jamais donné
ton nom j' t'ai préservé parce que je
voulais pas du tout parler de toi je
voulais faire attention je voulais moi
je je je veux juste que la vérité éclate
comment c qu'il veut
reprendre non c'est pas
possible et donc donc j'ai pas parlé de
tout ça mais ce qui éit très l'important
c'est que Yanis mais tu sais pas tout
enfin Yanis à l'époque tu super pote
avec BR tu avais du mal à blirer Yanis
c'est un peu drôle quoi on on est
d'accord on est d'accord que il était
bien dans ton appartement en 2005 oui
mais pas en septembre puisque Bruno fait
sa rentrée déjà c'est FA et vous pinez
l'OP alors est-ce que vous avez un
dernier mot à nous dire à dire à
Lionel ben je vois pas trop vous disez
qu'il était très pote avec Bruno là
ouais tu t'entendais hper bien avec
Bruno je vois pas pourquoi d'un coup tu
retournes ta veste comme ça mais je
retourne pas ma veste c'est juste qu'à
un moment donné il faut dire la vérité
et connais toi la vérité c'est que Yanis
a été abusé selon
Yanis je crois et moi je crois
certainement plus Yanis que moi je crois
Bruno voilà voilàok voilà
alors vous vous faire une idée également
et c'est bien qu'on ait eu la version de
de pénéope ce soir merci
Pénélope ben merci à toi cy c'est tout
ce que j'ai le droit de dire non mais
non vous voulez dire autre chose allez-y
bah moi je voulais dire quelque chose
parce que j'ai eu l'avocat de l'avocat
de Bruno il y a pas longtemps et euh il
semblerait que beaucoup de gens sur
Paris sache une information qui va être
divulguée demain dans les journaux il
semblerait que Yanis a été abusé par
quelqu'un d'autre que Bruno de ses 9 ans
à ses 13 ans et étonnamment pourquoi ça
ça ne ressort nulle part et pourquoi il
n'a pas apporté plainte pour ça donc je
voudrais juste savoir et peut-être que
Yanis donne une réponse à ça parce que
là on fait un tafoin médiatique autour
de ça avec absolument aucune preuve
d'ailleurs Yanis n'a toujours pas porté
plainte Bruno attend n'attend que ça il
le dossier qui est prêt dit s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît laissez parler là
il n'a toujours pas porté plainteheure
Act j'ais au téléphone il y a encore pas
évidemment il y a encore une heure et il
n'a il n'a pas porté plainte voilà bah
si elle le dit c'est qu'il a pas porté
plainte donc c'est pas la peine de dire
l'avocate va dire ils ont dit qu'il avit
porter plainte on attendra quand il il a
dit j'accuse Bruno de il a pas dit je
porte plainte merci P d'autrre chose
pénéop VO là je pense qu'on VO on a fait
le tour revendrait pour autre chose avec
plaisir merci merci beaucoup Penelope
merci d'avoir été avec nous y